le Mur de l'Atlantique documentaire
signé par Jérôme prieur du pas de calis
à Biaritz ces vestiges sont encore
présents sur nos côtes et ce film vous
venez de le voir est venu nous rappeler
que cette muraille érigée entre 1942 et
1944 fut de loin la plus vaste opération
de collaboration économique de l'État
français sous l'occupation bienvenue
Jérôme
prieur c'est donc vous qui avez réalisé
ce film sur ce fameux mur de la
Atlantique vous êtes écrivain
réalisateur auteur d'une vingtaine décès
d'une bonne trentaine de films le plus
souvent comme ici d'ailleurs à caractère
historique ce documentaire que nous
venons de voir a été accompagné lors de
sa première diffusion d'un livre qui est
un intitulé Mur de l'Atlantique monument
de collaboration disponible dans la
collection Histoire des éditions point
quel a été le déclic Jérôme prieur pour
réaliser ce ce documentaire pourquoi
est-ce que vous êtes attaqué de front
euh à ce mythe d'un chantier
intégralement réalisé sous la contrainte
des Allemands parce que le mythe c'était
celui-là mais n'allons pas trop vite
j'ai découvert cette histoire en lisant
un gros livre passionnant sur l'histoire
économique de Jean-Claude Azra et Renaud
drochebrune qui est mort l'année
dernière prématurément qui s'appelle les
patrons sous l'Occupation un gros livre
racontant des tas de cas de de de de
comportc de collab des diverses formes
voilà et puis dans ce livre il y a un
chapitre sur une entreprise qui
s'appelle saint rapt et Briss qui est
condamné pour fait de collaboration
économique à la fin de la guerre et
leur la défense de cette entreprise
c'est d'expliquer qu'ils ont pas voulu
ils ont voulu une collaboration de haut
niveau quoi c'est-à-dire que il
voulaient être reconnu à leur juste
valeur et ne pas construire comme
d'autres entreprises le Mur de
l'Atlantique pas être juste des maçons
voilà et là tout à coup ça a été un
déclic parce que comme la plupart des
français sauf sur les côtes de France
comme la plupart des français pour moi
le Mur de l'Atlantique c'est une œuvre
Allemande c'est un ouvrage allemand
construit par l'organisation t par des
entreprises allemandes et je n'imaginais
pas une seconde que les Français étaient
concernés et donc voilà j'ai et vous
avez tiré le fil finalement j'ai tiré le
fil j'ai construit un projet à l'époque
et puis pendant 10 ans j'ai pas pu le
faire parce qu'on me répondait oh la
Seconde Guerre mondiale ça n'intéresse
personne
bon voilà des choses comme ça et puis
finalement par un heureux concours de
circonstances 10 ans plus tard vers vers
vers l'an 2010 à peu près j'ai pu faire
ce film et finalement c'était une chance
que j'ai pu que j'ai dû attendre c'était
une chance parce que entre-temps euh il
y a des chercheurs qui travaillent au au
sein d'un d'un groupe de recherche du
CNRS qui ont vraiment travaillé la
question des sources travaillé la
question de l'histoire économique et
donc dans le film il y a il y a diverses
sortes d'historiens mais il y a aussi
des historiens qui sur un plan local sur
un plan monographique ont travaillé et
donc ça a donné je pense la qualité
d'information au film et vous l'avez dit
hein ce film à 1 ans maintenant ça a
fait l'effet d'une bombe hein lors de sa
première diffusion parce que évidemment
vous attaquiez à un mythe et dans
l'imaginaire collectif c'était bien un
édifice qui avait été édifié entièrement
sous la contrainte des Allemands les
entreprises françaises les ouvriers he
mis à contribution à l'occasion de ce
chantier n'avit donc pas tous été
réquisitionnés c'est ce que vous
démontrez chiffre à l'appui dans votre
film vous l'avez découvert au fur et à
mesure du tournage des interviews que
vous avez réalisé justement auprès des
historiens que vous citez non c'est
quelque chose que j'ai découvert tout de
suite grâce à mes lectures grâce aux
historiens grâce à une thèse d'un d'un
précurseur qui s'appelle Rémy Deken qui
malheureusement n'est pas dans le film
mais qui montrait à quel point il y
avait une collusion économique entre les
entreprises françaises et l'organisation
T qui qui a étit chargé de de gérer le
le chantier mais ce que j'ai trouvé très
intéressant c'est c'est de m'apercevoir
que la l'opinion commune est toujours
aujourd'hui répète le le Mur de
l'Atlantique a été construit par les
Allemands par des travailleurs
réquisitionnés des des entreprises
réquisitionnés des travailleurs forcés
et c'est c'est jamais faux c'est ce
genre de de discours sauf que c'est ça
correspond à une période donnée du Mur
de l'Atlantique ça correspond plutôt à
la fin aux années à la fin de l'année 43
quand Romel est chargé de de de
surveiller les côtes c'est là qu'on peut
parler d'un d'un travail forcé pour un
certain nombre d'ouvriers qui sont sur
ces chantier les réfugiés espagnols
fournis par l'état français de de
Philippe Pétin notamment il y a les
réfugiés espagnols il y a même des des
des Juifs français ou étrangers qui sont
sont amenés sur les camps il y a il y a
diverses situations et notamment il y a
la situation des des bases maritimes
quoi qui sont énorme indestructible je
pense que dans 5000 ans elles seront
toujours là nous ne le verrons pas mais
et là c'est base ces bases militaire ont
été ont demandé tellement de main-
d'œuvre que il y avait beaucoup de
main-dœuvre forcé mais au nom de cette
main-dœuvre forcé qui a été un des
éléments de la construction du chantier
on a réécrit l'histoire et on s'est
arrangé
avec cette légende qui consiste à penser
que les entreprises françaises n'y sont
pour rien que seul celles qui avaiit un
un fusil dans le rein ont pu y
participer ce qui est d'ailleurs votre
démonstration dans ce film est très
étayée hein du point de vue des chiffres
je vais en citer quelques-uns ils sont
dans le documentaire quelques 15000
entreprises hexagonales auraient été
misise au final à contribution en
1941 60000 ouvriers français volonire
ouvriers volontaire étai mis au service
de la Tode hein cette fameuse
organisation de la construction du 3è
rche pour passer à 150000 et là nous
sommes à la fin 1942 la construction de
ce mur a déjà commencé alors et puis
200000 ouvriers volontaires au printemps
1943 chiffres précis volumineux euh qui
effectivement étaille votre
démonstration où est-ce que vous avez
trouvé toutes ces données bah les
historiens ont travaillé sur le plan
local c'est-à-dire ou par branche ou
mais jamais j'ai si j'ai fait ce film et
si ensuite j'ai fait ce livre c'est que
aucune vue synthétique n'est n'était
donné et que toujours aujourd'hui aucune
vue synthétique de ce chantier qui est
quand même le premier chantier de la
collaboration économique n'existe quoi
je suis le premier et le seul voilà mais
ce que je voudrais pas et c'est le point
de vue du film aussi c'est jouer à
postériori le rôle un peu facile du
justicier qui vient 70 80 ans après les
fêtes ce que je je trouve anormal c'est
qu'on en parle pas qu'on ne reconnaisse
pas les choses mais ce que je trouve
important à montrer c'est que même pour
les travailleurs volontaires ou même
pour les entreprises volontaires entre
guillemets il y a dans la volonté de
participer à quelque chose une part de
contraintinte c'est-à-dire que on est
dans un pays dévasté il y a un chômage
énorme il y a plus de il y a une
activité économique qui tourne au
ralenti donc il y a cette ce chantier
qui est une auè mais au nom au nom de ça
au nom de cet argument je suis très
étonné qu'on ne veuille pas en parler
qu'on fasse comme si euh les pauvres
travailleurs les pauvres entreprises
n'avaient pas eu d'autres choix si elles
ont eu un autre elles auraient eu
d'autres choix mais elles ne l'ont pas
elles ne l'ont pas suivi vous démontrez
que la propagande de wishu a joué un
grand rôle notamment en disant que ça
permettait ce chantier permettait de de
résoudre notamment le le chômage le le
rôle de la propagande de wishi euh pour
ce pour cette construction de du Mur de
l'Atlantique pour dire quoi c'est
de faire comprendre au aux ouvriers à la
main-dœuvre peu qualifiée française ou à
la
main-dœuvre périphérique comme ça que il
y a une occasion de travail et que tout
travail est bon à prendre et donc les
les les organismes qui Avichi sont
chargés de centraliser de drainer les
travailleurs bah sa' faire s'active et
donc
les Allemands ont là un serviteur zellé
sous la sous la figure des des des
administrations de Vichy alors il y a un
un un intervenant un historien dans ce
film qui nous dit finalement on pouvait
aussi être entrepreneur dans le BTP
participer à ce chantier le jour et être
résistant la nuit je chématise hein mais
céit un petit peu
çaéité V vrai oui c'est vrai c'est vrai
c'est vrai il y a des cas quand il y a
eu des procès c'est après la Libération
il y a des entrepreneurs comme ça qui
ont utilisé cet argument qui n'est pas
qui n'est pas faux hein voilà ce qui par
contre est plus douteux c'est parce
qu'on pourrait vous pourriez me demander
mais pourquoi vous avez F vous n'avz pas
filmé de d'ouvriers ou de personnes qui
ont travaillé sur le chantier du Mur de
l'Atlantique bon j'ai filmé que des
historiens je voulais pas mélanger les
les les genres mais pourquoi je n'ai pas
filmé de d' er du Mur de l'Atlantique
parce que à l'époque où je l'ai où j'ai
fait le film les derniers survivants
étaient des pauvres vieillards quoi
disons et j'aurais trouvé ça douteux de
ma part de filmer des vieilles personnes
qui n'étaient pas responsabl de du
chantier d'une part et qui d'autre part
souvent j'en ai rencontré m'ont souvent
dit pour se dédoiner d'une forme de
mauvaise conscience inévitable oui on a
travaillé mais on a tout fait pour
saboter le Mur de l'Atlantique on
mettait je l'ai entendu plus d'une fois
on mettait de la farine dans le sable
enfin des choses comme ça qui ne sont
que des fables évidemment à une époque
de pénurie comment vous pouvez mettre de
la farine dans le sable et la meilleure
preuve en peut-être qu' il y a encore
une multitude hein de vestiges
aujourd'hui on présente sur nos côtes
entre le Pas de Calais et et biarit pour
la France mais rappelons que ce ce
fameux mur allait jusqu'aux côtes
norvégienne
4400 km oui et ça ça ça c'est du solide
f c'est des bon alors bien sûr
aujourd'hui il y a des blocoses il y a
des bunkers qui sont minés par le par la
mer et cetera par les intempéries et
tout ça mais c'est un problème c'est un
problème pour les communes qui voudrai
quelquefois se débarrasser de ces
vestiges compromettants alors que
d'autres souhaitent au contraire les
garder parce que ce sont des vestiges
sur le territoire français de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale il y en a pas beaucoup
d'autres et mais c'est c'est c'est de la
construction robuste il y a pas de doute
ça donc le sabotage si sabotage il a eu
je veux bien croire que des des ouvriers
sur des chantiers et freiner le
mouvement voilà mais ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre quand même c'est pour ça que
il y a le secret je pense c'est ce qu'il
faut bien comprendre c'est que c'est une
une activité économique qui a concerné
beaucoup de gens pas seulement les
ouvriers du bâtiment pas seulement les
maçons mais aussi le petit électricien
le petit plombier le blanchisseur et
cetera et cetera il nous reste 2 minutes
Jérôme prieur euh un des historiens que
vous interviewwez dans ce documentaire
nous dit finalement ce ce mur le 6 juin
1944 et finalement dans la mémoire
collective on a beaucoup parlé de ce mur
ce fameux jour du 6 juin 1944 ce fameux
mur il n'aura duré que 4 He si on exclut
c'est vrai le débarquement sur omaa
Beach qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire bah
que ça a été surtout je pense une
forteresse de propagande quoi une man
manière de dire à la population
française vous êtes défendu mais vous
êtes prisonnier vous êtes encerclé vous
ne pouvez pas sortir quoi je pense qu'il
y a cette fonction de dire que l'Europe
est une forteresse même si cette
forteresse est une forteresse de de de
paille enfin on peut dire c'est
paradoxal parce que cette forteresse
elle tient aujourd'hui on peut la voir
sur les plages et en même temps elle a
été évidemment de peu d'efficacité
puisque c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire
au vu de ce qui s'est passé du côté des
SCOT normande ce fameux 6 juin 1944
dernière chose l'épuration
l'épuration judiciaire d'après guerre ne
ne semble-t-il pas passé ou très peu par
les entreprises du BTP qui sont qui ont
participé à ce fameux chantier
pourquoi il fallait reconstruire la
France oui ben il y a eu il y a un
historien qui pas dans le film qui
s'appelle Hervis jolie qui avait une
formule très jolie si j'ose dire il
disait l'épuration économique a entre
guillemets entre parenthèses
provisoirement fermé la parenthèse exist
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a eu une volonté de
de punir les responsables de les vrais
responsables de cette collaboration
économique mot qui est difficile à
employer aujourd'hui pour un certain
nombre d'historiens on préfère parler de
coopération plutôt de collaboration bon
c'est une collaboration économique et
pourquoi parce que bah
pénalement il y avait des il y avait des
tensions des alliés des alliances il
fallait quand même voilà et puis il y a
une volonté de de de dépuration
professionnelle qui a existé fiscale qui
existé mais très vite qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé bah il fallait reconstruire
il fallait reconstruire la France et
donc quelles étaient les entreprises qui
étaient en état de marche bah celles qui
avaient entretenu leur outil de travail
qui avaient fait fonctionner leurs
ouvriers leurs machines leurs élévateurs
le le le CIT leur bulldozer et cetera et
cetera et donc cette épuration
économique a été très limitée il y a il
y a des dossiers qui permettent aux
historien aujourd'hui de savoir ce qui
s'est passé après la guerre mais forcé
de constater qu'elle a été très très
modeste et puis vous l'avz dit au début
de notre entretien c'est l'un de ces
dossiers hein qui a été le déclic pour
vous pour réaliser ce ce documentaire
que nous avons vu dans cette émission
desbadoc à propos de ce fameux mur de
l'Atlantique merci beaucoup jum prieur
d'avoir participé à debadoc on a eu le
plaisir de présenter votre film à nos
téléspectateurs aujourd'hui vos
réactions ça sera sur
hashtagdbatdoc merci à Selma sali qui
m'a aidé comme à l'accoutumé à préparer
cette émission je vous donne rendez-vous
pour un prochain débat doc et ça sera
bien sûr avec son documentaire et son
débat à très
[Musique]
bientôt